The Joe Rogan Experience now the Great
Pyramid of Jesus is probably the most
stunning of all these ancient structures
and the the stones are immense and some
of them were cut from a quarry that's
hundreds of miles away
how do you think they did that well some
of them the granite in the Great Pyramid
comes from more than 500 miles to the
South
um if you look at the famous King's
chamber it's walls and its roof are the
ceiling of the king's chamber are all
made with gigantic Granite blocks
stunning details stunning detail those
those blocks on the king's chin the roof
of the king's chamber weighs 70 tons
each now egyptologists will tell you
that oh they could move heavy blocks
because they put them on wet sand and
they push them along on wet sand well
maybe if you're just at ground level
that will do but when you're 350 feet
above the ground as you are in the
king's chamber that won't do it all I
don't know how they did it all I know is
they did it I don't think anybody knows
how they did it how they lifted those
stones how they brought them up to that
level I think we're looking again at a
lost technology and it was this ancient
apocalypse twelve thousand eight hundred
years ago that wiped that from the human
memory banks almost completely not
entirely completely because they were
survivors but
removed most of it Ronda will tell you
sea level rise it creates a powerful
high energy Zone anything that was
existing on those on those flooded
coastlines has just been pounded to hell
I mean talk about it rather
well yeah I mean it's going to be a lot
more energetic than now I mean imagine
your sea level rising at three or four
times at least faster than we've seen
rise in the last century and within
their juxtaposed are these episodes of
very rapid sea level rise so
you're talking about a a very energetic
intertidal zone and anything that's
there
short of large megalithic blocks is
going to be utterly obliterated by the
time the processes is through and I
think that this is one of the things
that you know the archaeologists and the
prehistorians people are looking at that
have failed to take into account the
severity of these events we're talking
about because the question always says
where are the artifacts where's the
pottery where is the the evidence that
this civilization existed and I have two
responses to that one
you don't realize the extent of the the
total remodeling of this planetary
surface that took place
because I mean we could get into some of
the stuff here I have tons of images
where I think maybe we'll get a chance
to pull up a couple of really awesome
Drone footage here before we're done but
once you begin to wrap your head around
this you go really
you know it's like imagine that you drop
an atomic bomb on a city and it
completely obliterates it and then a
short while later you drop another one
on the same place what's going to be
left and then Ten Thousand Years Twenty
Thousand Years goes by what are you
going to be what are you going to find
what are you going to look for you know
it's going to be just Rubble it gets
reincorporated just into the geological
stratum and this is going to be very
difficult to
um differentiate for for example from
what's called a conglomerated rock which
is basically we have just a huge jumble
of broken rock cemented together right
now within there there could be all
kinds of stuff that's not even
recognized as being artificial in the
sense that humans had anything to do
with it the other thing is is when we
talk about these ancient Technologies
if we're only looking for a mere
reflection of ourselves we could
Overlook it completely because there is
I think there's evidence that exists now
I mean modern some Modern researchers
whose work has been buried or suppressed
I think we're getting very close to
rediscovering some of the things that um
our ancient ancestors were up to and
maybe this would be worth a whole show
in itself we could dive into this and I
don't want to get into that today but
what kind of Technologies are you
talking about
um
but
well I just
I shouldn't really get into it get into
it get into it rattle we got to get into
it okay well we've opened the door sir
okay well okay
the passing of the HDMI cable the
passing a sacred moment
well
there are people out there now who have
been working on
trying to ReDiscover that and and again
I don't want to digress too much into
this now because I I would really rather
be able to give a whole treatment of it
and it might kind of derail us a little
bit from this but there are people
who've been working on these things for
for decades now basically in secret in
secret and I've had the privilege of
talking to some of these people over the
last six or seven years and right now as
we're speaking there's a there's a group
of people who
who are basically going to open source a
whole lot of stuff in the next three
months so it can never get suppressed
again and that's why I'd like to come
back and talk anymore I'd love to have
you come back and talk about it but we
got to talk about it a little bit now
ah okay well uh
there's a laboratory right now in the
Maldives that's been building prototypes
using these technological principles
which are based on implosion rather than
explosion and the inspiration for the
Tesla Tesla's ideas are part of it I
think you mentioned Tesla's ideas are
very much a part of it
um yes Tesla's ideas are very much a
part of it
um so is I don't know if you ever Victor
schauberger who did the work with water
and discovered uh yeah
look at um Jamie could you look up
Victor oh I have the uh I have the cable
now don't I take it back let me find it
well no no let me let me uh pull
something up here and uh
I think the key thing is we're looking
at technologies that are not the same as
ours yes and that's probably why
archaeologists can't see them because
they're looking for us in the past and
they're not open to the possibility that
there are whole other kinds of
technology that could be used right I
always go back to the ancient Egyptian
Traditions that speak of priests
chanting as these huge blocks were
lifted into the air were they using some
kind of sound uh effect some kind of
some kind of use of sound that was able
to manipulate matter we know that sound
can manipulate matter as a matter of
fact but they're lifting these blocks
again and again it appears in Ancient
Ancient Egyptian Traditions the notion
that we could lift huge blocks with
sound seems absurd to archaeologists and
yet it's there in the traditions of the
egyptologists and what Randall's talking
about now is people who are working on a
whole alternative path of technology and
maybe that's a rediscovery of the kind
of technologies that were used by A Lost
Civilization I think that's what's
important about what you're saying is
that we have this
very limited idea of Technology based on
what we've experienced yeah but if you
had anatomically similar human beings
that live for thousands and thousands of
years stuff just keeps on getting older
if you think about the amount of
progress that we've achieved as modern
humans just in the last few hundred
years if you go back 400 years to now
it's a stunning amount of achievement
absolutely stunning and if you have a
completely different path of Technology
yeah one that's not utilizing internal
combustion engines and cranes and yeah
and the like that we experience leverage
mechanical advantage everything that our
our Tech is based around something
that's insanely Advanced tens of
thousands of years of a different path
yeah and that's that may be what we're
looking at and that may begin to explain
these these otherwise inexplicable
monuments that have survived
uh Jamie do I need
there we go
this is the work of Nikola Tesla and he
was again this is way too much for us to
get in today that's why we need to
devote a whole
session talking about this okay
um but this is uh this was the
inspiration you know his work was
suppressed a lot of his patents were
were
taken sealed up by the U.S government
for whatever reason I don't know but
this is some of the stuff
that's now being developed using his
ideas plus some of the others
um this is the man I've been talking to
for the last seven years Malcolm bendall
yes
and uh again I don't want to get into it
today but like here's an example of what
they're doing this is a generator that
has no moving Parts it's all based on
Geometry
pure geometry and the and here's the
basic idea is I think I understand it at
this point
resonance frequencies everything
vibrates have you ever like if if we had
a an electric razor we plugged it in
turned it on set it on this table
because it's going to move around isn't
it you ever seen that yeah that's the
beginning of the concept because it's
vibrating everything vibrates at a
frequency and if you know that frequency
you can control things and I think
that's the basic idea of what we're
looking at here and it's all based upon
the ancient numbers
and they're developing Technologies
right now and they have been
I was recently contacted and given the
go-ahead that I could talk I've been
sitting on this for seven years without
talking about it because they asked me
not to talk about it until they had
their patents in place in their
licensing that's all happened since last
summer
so we're now free to talk about it so
that's what I'm saying I think it'd be
good idea to get me back on here we can
look at it I'm going to lay this on
Graham so he can look at it too because
I really want to get Graham's feedback
on this I mean would it be fair to say
that there's an element of a rediscovery
of a less technology from the past I
think it would be fair to say that yes
and so through somehow through this
technology they're able to move stones
or cut stones or All the Above All the
Above and and even transport them
whoa what is all this well this is the
model and this is diagramming all the
frequencies of the elements and what
their vibrational frequencies are and
the numbers that measure those
frequencies
and they're all the numbers we get from
looking at these ancient Traditions that
occur over and over and over again that
I've been talking about in my sacred
geometry classes for decades without
knowing what the gate the final result
was going to be
so this this inventor who's working with
this small group contacted me and this
is what he told me he said
you built a foundation he said you laid
the foundation with your work on Ancient
geometry and I built a house on top of
it
that's what he said so for seven years
he's been supplying me with
all the information I have copies of all
the patents I have videos of the testing
of the prototypes and Mazda the car
manufactured in Japan is getting ready
to do a 25 million dollar testing of
some of these prototypes that they
believe they can retrofit internal
combustion engines with and there's over
a hundred they've developed over 100
patents on some of this stuff
and it's amazing and will be the fuel
well
plasmoids plasmoids as it says here are
donut or toroidal-shaped clusters of net
protons or net electrons that once
captured and placed into a toroidal
orbit are capable of absorbing storing
and releasing enormous amounts of energy
within their self-generated and
structured electromagnetic containment
field
plasmoids in effect function as an
atomic battery that can be self-charging
due to its ability to convert matter to
available clean energy so it's a lot to
get into and I think it would take us
kind of off off what we're here to talk
about but today at least what's
promising is that there is some at least
research or understanding and it's
actually quite mature at this point and
in order to avoid the kinds of Fate that
befell Tesla and Reich Robert
Oppenheimer Victor schauberger and so
many others that were working in these
fields all kind of converging on the
same insight
it's been conducted in secret the
laboratory has been that they've been
developing this is in the Maldives so
that it's been
um immune from government interference
and
um now I think it's about ready to go
the next what is the motivation of the
suppressing of this information
I think in case of Tesla wasn't it
military the fear of military
applications I also I also think that
you know there are huge corporations
that have very large investments in a
particular path of technology which is
ours right and for somebody to come up
with a whole new path of Technology it's
very threatening to them uh and and much
better from their point of view to
suppress it or if they can't suppress it
to kind of buy it and hide it and keep
things keep things on the track that
they're that they're on now I would say
that's the motive and maybe for people
that are curious about this and maybe
even skeptical
consider the massive change that nuclear
power provided us whereas before the
1940s this was unheard of yes this even
the concept of it and all of a sudden
now we have nuclear power nuclear
weapons the most profound power known to
man currently
God help us it's a power for use by
adults but unfortunately it's delinquent
children who are leading our world right
now the leaders of our planet the
politicians out there that they're just
complete [ __ ] I can't think of any
of them who I feel any respect for
whatsoever and it's they who are in
charge of this frightening terrifying
technology we just aren't mature enough
as a civilization to manage technology
like that you have to get that level of
level of maturity